hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim I didn't forget I was
just taking a dramatic pause anyway so
we just cleared out this dungeon here
air cave I finally got my hands on a
two-hander oh wait what's up with my
tail what's going on there i tells he's
like is that for balance
cuz it's a giant no there goes okay
that's weird anyway I just got my giant
to hinder and doesn't this look right
well I mean not the Imperial armor but
just look
oh hello handles I've never really done
much with like the food and old toys
empty barrel known point large sack
taters chest yes yeah we glibness like
it i must be getting close to my weight
cap I mean I did drop those swords but
I've been picking up a lot of crap
what's in there I don't know I don't
know
or or hello-o super-exciting dink you
think you think that if you were mining
you would put a little more effort into
your swings just BAM and not just dink
dink dink dink yeah
I've always wondered because in in yeah
when I played last the herbs I know the
herbs respawn after so long or I don't
know but does or ever or is there only
like a certain amount of ore in the
entire world as that would be something
kind of be restrictive I suppose but
it'd be something I mean there are a lot
of mines like when I I I haven't played
this game like hardly anywhere through
it so I have my progress through the
game is not far I've not done much at
least into the main story I've like
[ __ ] around doing side quests most at
a time just enjoying everything about it
and there is a lot to enjoy about this
game I mean just look at this thing
harvest firewood oh I got a I can cut
down trees cuz you always do that really
could you I don't know maybe that's a
mod of mine anyway
look at me go I'll put my sword away you
don't want to scare anyone ah look at me
look at me
oops no look at me oh so handsome fern
Argonian I suppose somebody's my
computer's slowing down a couple times
here I don't know what that's all about
but out for you I'll fix it later it's
not terrible
hello its ralof okay be your buddy I'm
gonna coming for you
I forget is azure dragon
I've always wondered if you know well I
don't know what I've always wanted
something else
hello alright baby give me that fire axe
yeah what you gonna do about it
what other maras mercy would help you
see you give me that see Ferriero be
here I heard that Wulfric had been do
sir girder I'm fine
dude you're I'm fine now I am are you
hurt
what's happened what's happened and
who's this
I want yesterday argh onion ever I'm
ready
I'm an imperial armor I owe him my life
damn straight is there somewhere we can
talk
there's no telling when the news from
Hell gamer reached Imperials helghan
something happened yes you're right
follow me III say me even here you would
see it dragon flying overhead I need
your help with something
what is it woman come here oh dunk on
the job again pod just come here how do
I walk right shift there we go what are
you doing here Rael oh I'll be right
down
honeybee raid dude oh man this place is
gonna be perfect for my accents Oh such
cinematic walking
hello girder oh you so fine No Oh what
are you talking about kids Hospital done
in Ching
I'm trying this if you see any Imperial
soldiers coming oh mama I want to stay
and talk with uncle raela oh look at you
almost a grown man not even close be
long before you'll be joining the fight
yourself yes send kids off to fight
that's awesome
your great example ralof no oh you're
taking a sit now what's going on you two
look pretty well done in uh-huh I can't
remember when I last slept oh good
question
where to start there's a dragons you
heard about all four it was true there's
also a dragon he Rios ambushed us
outside dark and did you hear about the
dragon like they knew exactly where we'd
be that was two days ago now hmm we
stopped in Helghan this morning and I
thought it was all over I just lined up
to the headsman's block and ready to
start chopping they got one of you
cowards
yeah they when there was a dragon Oh
freak a fair trial priests for fighting
for your own people
uh-huh all of Skyrim would have seen the
truth then dragon what Dan there we go
of nowhere I don't know where a dragon
it a knife
I can hardly believe it Macedon well I
guess ad I was there attacked like a
skeletal there strange as it sounds
we'd be dead if not for that dragon ah
and me managed to sleep I face that
dragon like a bow really the first to
make it to river would nobody else has
come up the south road today as far as I
know uh-huh no one bad enough too bad
acid am i right I don't know why I hate
to put your family in danger
Oh nonsense you and your friend are
welcome to stay here as long as you need
obvious friend worry about the Imperials
any friend of ray luvs is a friend of
mine I'm not your friend he's his friend
house stay as long as you like you gave
me a key here so we're just let me know
okay so I'll take everything you're
giving me give you every of that there
we go there is something you could do
for me what all of us oh wow
yadi needs to know if there's a dragon
on the loose Riverwood is defenseless
okay we need to get word to your vulgar
if in Whiterun to send weights but man
if you'll do that for me I'll be in your
deck okey-dokey
thanks sister I knew we could count on
you uh-huh yeah whatever
anyone else escaped it was fake
did don't worry I'm sure he made it out
how do you know take more than a dragon
to stop over it okay guys get ready for
the 200 part series of watching me chop
wood Oh Nardi this is gonna be boring
yeah yes
aren't you see how awesome I hit that
wood oh yeah stack that would make sure
it's balanced yeah yes yes that's the
greatest ever I don't think I can do a
better one oh oh oh oh wait a minute
yes okay that's boring I forgot that you
could actually that are I forgot that it
took three times do you have to sit
through it and watch it but you can sell
the word correct
can you who's it gonna be right
oh is that it was that hurl or hug yeah
no but in very but would trade is this
each broken loose her hug hug hug hug
hug hug hug hug
Hogarth who's alright I don't know but
I've got firewood apparently oh maybe I
can just sell in the store here we go
River with traitor well one of us has to
do something huh I said no no pictures
no theatrics no thief chasing no well
what are you going to do then huh let's
hear it we are done talking about this
okay Oh a customer that time you noticed
sorry you had to hear that
hello I don't know what you yeah yeah we
don't have a bill yeah yeah break in on
ornaments solid gold in the shape of a
dragon's claw uh-huh you could trust me
this random point you're coming in from
my last shipment it's yours if you bring
my claw back okay now owner you find the
come on trinkets odds and ends yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay okay
now I need to offload this all this junk
that I've had a 5-iron daggers that one
longbow
oh [ __ ] those my pickaxe I said weapon
that's not our weapon um let's see steel
mace go keep the woodcutters s cuz I
want to try to chop down a tree I don't
need
do that what raps yeah yeah and yeah all
that all that all that I'm not gonna do
any magic stuff well I mean I'm going to
do magic stuff I'm gonna need to do
magic stuff eventually just to survive
I mean it's essential for some spells
you absolutely do need to use it okay
that's good that's okay I'm gonna keep
those you need to make potions I get rid
of that because I already learned that
and these can go do you have any books
stuff like oak flesh something you need
Ward I think or I don't know I I never
delved into a lot of the different
spells and I think there's a mod that I
have that actually adds a little more
interesting stuff to the magic but let
me get we get flesh and for now Ward's
more of a mage thing but oh pleasure
please now if you're going to get those
deep yeah yeah shut up guy I know
oh falls Barrow north of town yes yes
now you don't have to go do you
oh really well I think your new helper
here needs a guy
oh yeah baby no I buy the eight fine but
only to the edge of town
oh yeah to the edge of town baby yeah
show me the way
come on Camila how you doing
we have to go through town and across
the bridge to get to bleak falls Barrow
okay yeah whatever you say the mountain
just over the buildings where that one
oh there okay oh the Smith I need to
stop by the Smith hang on oh my god
every day we get I see the grindstone if
you've got the raw materials good you're
not selling are you hard run to lay low
market recently by many asses screwed
you some what I would go on baby are we
going oh yeah
Hey look cabbages those wood menus must
be mad hiding out there
mmm those old crypts are filled with
nothing but traps trolls and who knows
okay screw you lady I'm not even gonna
wait around for you ah I don't care
you're cute but you just standing there
no not today I got stuff to do I got
people to kill yeah I got trees chopped
down all right
that's pretty okay Perdue um which way
this way oh I don't know my memory is
failing me I have no idea up here yes no
I don't know
let's go to war oh my god huh I lost
control
I went berserk her on that wolf well I
got blood on my screen did I still chop
down trees can I chop down them I want
to try out hang on what I've got it I
have an axe
do I need to equip it really I really
try this try this [ __ ] what up come on
Oh me another tree get me another tree
hmm that's one yes yeah haha that's
awesome
you just get firewood bite but fire was
heavy isn't it other miscellaneous I
don't know yeah fire was like yeah I
keep Isles up like crap okay nevermind
screw that
oh there we go yeah back to the
Berserker barbarian barbarian Berserker
Argonian barbarian Berserker I'm not
going to even going the right way I've
no idea all that just up there I don't
know but there's something over here
that I want to take care of up nope nope
no actually I'm out of time I will take
care of whatever is over here in just a
second or in the next episode so thank
you everyone so much for watching as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye